avec alexis poulain éditorialistes
bonjour à vous alexis poulain alors il
ya de nombreuses réticences au passage
ou tard on le voit bien des
manifestations à venir cet après midi de
la part de la population mais aussi des
professionnels
les restaurateurs et les cafetiers des
responsables aussi de centres
commerciaux qui vont devoir dont
contrôle et se passe le carnet de route
de l'exécutif et skil et nabeul dans ces
conditions
cd tout ce qui est en train d'être fait
on a l'impression qu'il est chez contre
l'intérêt général contre l'avis même des
français puisque le conseil de
économique et social avait été voté
contre à cette idée de passer ni terre
il ya de ça quelques semaines que
globalement malgré les sondages je ne
vois pas l'intérêt d'un pass sanitaire
qui a été enlevée dans la plupart des
pays qui n'ont mis en place
et là on voit bien que le gouvernement
ait gêné parce que ils demandent à des
professions de devenir des contrôleurs
ils ne peuvent pas le faire évidemment
et que jean castex nous parle de
contrôle par les policiers en deuxième
instance de l'identité donc les
cafetiers et les restaurateurs
demanderont impasse sanitaire enfin la
preuve de demandes dont positivité oco
vide plutôt qu'autre chose n'est pas une
pièce d'identité donc on voit bien que
déjà là ça commence à être extrêmement
complexe mais ce qui est terrible avec
ce gouvernement d'idéologues qui est en
train de mettre en place des mesures
liberticides et certainement pas des
mesures sanitaires c'est que vous avez
un ministre de la santé qui nie le
mal-être des soignants qui nie les
démissions de soignants qui parle de
propagande
donc il ya vraiment là quelque chose de
dystopique de terribles entre des
dirigeants qui d'ailleurs ne met pas le
pastel terre pour l'assemblée nationale
comme le dit richard ferrand puisque le
conseil constitutionnel ne validerait
pas soi disant alors c'est étonnant et
puis la masse les autres qui eux sont
soumis à des contrôles permanents à ddd
des contraintes permanentes également
sous prétexte bien sûr de préserver la
santé des français alors c'est vrai
qu'il ya le volet liberticide qui pose
problème on voit bien avec les
manifestations mais il ya aussi le délai
d'application de ces mesures est ce
qu'il aurait fallu lui justement laisser
plus de temps aux français pourra
s'adapter
oui c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'ils font ils
essayent de décaler le vaccin pour les
plus jeunes c'est pas possible puisqu'il
a été ouvert trop tard donc on parle
maintenant de fin septembre même si jean
castex voudrait vacciner à l'école en
rendant possible la vaccination à
l'école ne signera pas de san passe
sanitaires pour la rentrée à l'école
mais ils reviendront sans doute sur leur
parole d'ici là et puis on voit bien que
il ya un manque de vaccins de doses
actuellement est donc là il veut pousser
en disant finalement nous allons ouvrir
5 millions et l'idée c'est de faire du
chiffre de passer de 40 millions de
français vaccinés à 50 millions de
français vaccinés en espérant qu'il y
ait là une immunité collective qui fasse
que l'économie puisse reprendre
mais rien ne garantit les masses que
reviennent les gestes barrières vont
continuer cette promesse d'un retour à
la normale avec la vaccination reste à
voir
elle n'a été vue nulle part encore
aujourd'hui la grande bretagne sera sans
doute un des indes et est un comme l'a
été israël pour ce qui est de la france
on est dans la phase de vaccination
pensant que cela permettra de mettre le
virus derrière nous on a l'impression
que le virus il est là pour durer et que
nos gouvernants ont bien du mal à faire
des mesures sanitaires puisqu'il
continue de fermer des lits il continue
de nier la souffrance au travail des
soignants et ils préfèrent contraindre
les français à la vaccination et à la
capacité finalement de vivre une vie
normale puisque tout est fait pour
empêcher les rassemblements les loisirs
également puisque finalement se passe à
lithaire il n'est pas utile dans les
transports est par contre il sera
demandé apparemment sur vos lieux de
travail puisque son passé sanitaire
certains pourraient se voir tout
simplement mis à la porte
alors à quoi s'attendre de la part à des
députés et des sénateurs qui vont
donc à examiner le projet de loi je ne
sais pas ça dépend un peu de de la
pensée politique philosophique de
certains députés sur le rapport qu'ils
ont aussi aux libertés publiques à la
devise de la république liberté égalité
fraternité ou si bien il cède aux
sirènes de la techno surveillance
pensant que c'est là un futur
souhaitable
on voit bien que même au simple de la
république en marche ça commence à
grincer des dents certains députés de la
majorité sont tout à fait contre ces
mesures liberticides se passe sanitaires
pour d'autres c'est la vaccination
obligatoire qui devrait être la loi et
puis on voit des rapports de travail du
sénat qui circule sur les réseaux
sociaux rapport officiel qui parle de
moyens numériques de gestion de crise où
il est question de bracelets pour
empêcher les gens de sortir chez eux où
il est question aussi de le rompre
finalement l'égalité entre les citoyens
qui est la base de notre pacte
républicain et c'est là vraiment un
débat profond sur qu'est ce que nous
voulons comment nous pouvons préserver
la démocratie libérale le cadre
républicain en crise sanitaire parce que
la crise sanitaire ne peut pas être une
excuse pour mettre en place un nouveau
monde qui n'a rien à voir avec le monde
des libertés d'égalité travers des
commissions et l'annoncent alexis
poulains de jean castex concernant les 5
millions de rendez-vous dans les quinze
jours
dans les centres de vaccination coup
d'accélérateur donc de la campagne pour
répondre à l'urgence de la situation
oui clairement ils ne veulent pas être
pris de court le gouvernement ne veut
pas être pris de court
en voyant qu'il n'y a pas assez de place
pour se faire vacciner avec des gens qui
souhaiteraient se faire vacciner pour
avoir se passe ce fameux graal et
pouvoir tout simplement voyager aller au
travail ne pas perdre leur travail
que va-t-il se passer quand on entend
madame borne à dire qu'ils sont en train
de prévoir des lois pour mettre à la
porte les gens qui n'auront pas de
sanitaires si ceux là n'ont pas pu se
faire vacciner c'est tout simplement
inaudible odieux et attentatoire aux
libertés est contraire au droit du
travail
donc aujourd'hui les syndicats ont
beaucoup de travail d'ailleurs certains
syndicats ont commencé à monter au
créneau syndicat des pompiers et des
soignants également mais d'autres
professions pour le faire et puis ça ne
répond pas à la question de pourquoi
certaines professions finalement en sont
exemptés par les députés voilà le passé
l'inter n'est pas nécessaire à
l'assemblée nationale ils les policiers
également aucune réponse du gouvernement
sur ce pour quoi
évidemment on peut avoir son idée quant
à ce choix de professions ciblées les
soignants qui ont eu droit à des
médailles quand ils ont géré le coc vide
avec des gants en plastique et des sacs
poubelles et qui maintenant sont montrés
du doigt s'il ne souhaite pas se faire
vacciner
on est vraiment là dans un monde que je
ne comprends plus que nous sommes
nombreux d'ailleurs à ne pas comprendre
puisque 2 15 jours en quinze jours le
gouvernement vote des lois contraires
aux lois qu'ils avaient voté auparavant
cette loi qui était discuté aujourd'hui
elle est contraire à celle qui avait été
voté il ya de ça quelques semaines
visiblement ça n'en boivent personne pas
même le conseil d'état qui semble
accepter ces dérives liberticides et
grave
merci beaucoup à vous à l'excès poulain
je rappelle que vous êtes éditorialistes